i did want to ask you about fantastic
four because i read what you said with
the emmys and i don't want to pry or ask
for details but
more generally because i again i think
uh
other people hearing about challenges
and how you overcame them can
be very helpful so walking away from an
experience
like that what would you say is maybe an
actionable
idea or a value you picked up from going
through that that you are now bringing
to the sets that you're on to make sure
everybody around you has an experience
for the better
um well i i think that the thing that
i always go back to on that one is that
i should have um
i think i should have listened to my
instincts followed my instincts more
you know like when my gut was telling me
like you probably shouldn't let that
slide what that person just said or you
know
if you're feeling a certain way about
how
um what an energy is like
and how that is affecting your
performance you're being paid to do a
certain thing
and if something is in the way of that
you know you have the right to speak up
and say i'm actually not able to
do what i am here to do because
of x y and z and you know i think that
speaking up is something that i really i
think that we all
probably learn it over and over again to
follow your instincts and if you're
feeling a certain
thing that is uneasy or whatever there's
a reason for it
um but because it was such a big movie
and it was like you know
again when you're in usually
except in this case when you're in a a
big
superhero movie they usually do
incredibly well
like almost always so you know even if
it's challenging or this or that or you
know not everything's perfect like it's
probably good for you to do it that was
sort of what i was
being told and also was telling myself
you know
and i don't regret doing it at all but i
do regret
not having um you know stood up for
myself
i i i regret that for sure because if my
daughter
ended up acting and was you know
was in a situation like that where she
felt like she couldn't speak up
meanwhile i'm a
i'm a pretty tough person and i do i
really do advocate for
myself um granted this was a few years
ago and maybe this situation was
different but if
if i was in that situation today it just
wouldn't have
it wouldn't have happened or it just
would have been a different
environment i think um so again like
good learning experience you know
absolutely and i appreciate you sharing
that because i
really am a big believer that someone
out there might might have need to have
heard that
from an actor they admire like you and
it could make all the difference
i also think asking people this is
another great great lesson that i
learned
asking other actors or and i learned
this lesson not just on this movie but
on a couple other after that
asking other actors what their
experience was like
working with either a producer or a
director
or another actor i never used to do that
and now i do because
i think that if you really respect
another actor
and they've worked with someone that
you're thinking about working with or
whatever
then you can learn a lot just by talking
to them
um and i'm i always say like if anyone
ever wants to ask me about my
experiences
um on things then please do because i
you know i think that it's
not always if you're in a position where
you can make a choice about doing
something or not doing something
um and we're not always sometimes you
just have to work
but if you if you're in a position where
you can doing the research not just with
the role but with the people that you're
about to work with
creatively is really important